let me ask you guys a question because I
because I talk about this on social
media and I've said that a younger woman
has
patience for for an attractive guy with
ambition and I heard
ambition there
um we've also got Melanie on the panel
who's 52 and I've said that older women
have a lot less patience for a guy with
a plan or some ambition to kind of have
the expectation that they've done
something with their lives by the time
they get to a certain age
um so I'm curious like Melanie um guy
that's hot but has a plan and some
ambition but is broke do you have
patience for a guy like that is that
something that you're willing to work
with or do you need a guy that kind of
like shows up with his act together
uh at this stage with my experience
there's so there's so much more
um
are you talking if I meet someone this
around my same age
yeah because I mean like like you know
we say sometimes in this space like I'll
tell guys not to play Captain Save A Hoe
right and I think women will probably
play after the age of 40
uh Captain Save A bro maybe right like
you know he's got all kinds of problems
in his life you have to swoop in and
deal with all this stuff but I've
noticed that women like as they get
older 35 40 plus they're like dude like
where's your house where's your car do
you have a stable job like you know you
make at least six figures because I got
my act together what's your aquaplex
sort of thing yeah there's a younger gal
maybe in her 20s will be like hey if
he's hot and he has a plan then I'll
work with him because he's got a got
some ambition so I'm just trying to
clarify that you know with the two
ladies over here because the age spread
yeah at my stage
especially to after going through a
divorce being married for so long having
four kids
I've had to do so much like personal
work and have been through so much
to meet a man that
is having the issues needs to get
through stuff this sounds really rude
but I'm not gonna do it I wish them well
you know it but I've had to face all
that and get to a certain point so I
would rather like you always say have
someone that compliments that same
amount of work and growth and experience
doesn't make them bad but I have met a
lot of guys 45 55
that are upside down and I just thought
well most guys my age are going to
probably been through divorce have kids
and have the same outlook on
just this plan and having yourself
together
and it doesn't always happen so no I
being broke
I
it's not my thing
I mean what I've seen anyways it's it's
generally a deal breaker for most older
women that are that are together you
know
um financially they don't like I mean
I'll pay it on this panel and I've said
it many times before but women don't
tend to share their product goals with
men right like they just want a guy to
show up and have this [__] together
basically right so it was like over 35
40.
well I'm gonna ask a question a little
more on that I want to double down real
quick
[Music]
um
but Melanie go ahead and finish your
thought and then I'll ask I was just
gonna what you and Rich talk about as
far as a man that's holding frame and
being at this stage in my life
understanding that
that is so
so appealing especially to me I can't
speak for a woman my age but to be able
to have a man that does hold frame and
is strong in that
frame like what is your understanding of
it if you have to explain it to like
your 21 year old
um so Amanda understands himself has his
assets together knows what he wants out
of life is focused on that versus women
to hold that stick with that and then
when a woman comes along that can pass
all these
tests to be in his frame they're such a
just a beauty in that and being able to
settle into that frame because you can
be more feminine you can
be the beauty while the man
holds the frame and
being just young and ambitious a guy
usually doesn't have a frame set yet
it's not a bad thing they just don't
they haven't had enough life experience
and that's that's how I feel but to step
into that and take a deep breath and be
like oh there's frame for a lot of women
they're going to be you know the guy's a
dick he's bossy he's this way and I'm
like no this is how it's supposed to be
when you're a woman
to step into that and let let him hold
the reins you know you can support so
much of it but there's so much you can
let go of and settle into being a woman
can you moth maybe
um you can explain frame to the ladies
as you see it yeah you guys explain that
I'm just gonna deal with this air
conditioner because it's way too loud
for me yeah listen I mean the whole the
whole idea of frame essentially the
frame is is it's a really when we say
frame it's like a picture frame it's
either and it's the life that you design
for yourself everybody is living a life
in a picture frame so to speak so what
is the picture of your life look like as
a man and in any relationship a man is
either entering the woman's frame or the
woman is entering into a man's frame and
so controlling the frame is really about
as a man are you going to let this woman
knock you off your purpose are you going
to let her infiltrate your life and you
stop doing things like chasing
excellence and going after your hobbies
and staying in good shape and making
money because
[Music]
women as a survival mechanism will
routinely test that man to ensure that
he is her best possible option you're
talking about you know competency tests
and hyperkin in a nutshell right there
and so is this man holding frame holding
frame is not about you know she does
whatever I say and I have to have her
toe the line it's are you the steadfast
Rock in the storm and is she willing to
leave her frame
to enter yours as a man so that's what
frame means as a man not not to
interrupt you but something I visualize
when you talk about a picture frame I
picture with the work I've done I have a
frame too right you do and then to be
able to step into a man's frame your
frame is a little softer
but it then forms into that man's frame
so you're supporting his frame you're
making his friends Stronger by stepping
in softening your frame and then letting
him hold your frame up
you're a compliment not a detriment to
his life yes and this this ties into
that question I was going to ask and I
saw Dez you were kind of nodding and
smiling looking good and and hopefully I
want you to get to that whatever point
you had but I want this is for Melanie
and Dez
one of the things we talk a lot about in
this space is that men age like wine
and the older they get generally the
better off they are but the caveat that
a lot of guys tend to miss is the
asterisk of if you do the work and if
you do the right things and a lot of
guys think they're just gonna wake up
one day in their early 40s and it's just
gonna be raining money and women and
they forget about the work part
so in your experiences because I think
you will I mean as you probably have the
earliest relationship so you're probably
dating more recently than any of the
other ladies in relationships since
Melanie as a single woman
is what you're seeing in a dating pool
are you seeing more of these guys that
have forgotten to do the work and
they're just 19 year old men and 45 year
old bodies what's what's sort of the
pool that you're seeing when it comes to
that age range of Ben
well like nowadays there's
well it's
it's harder for men
just because they have they have to
build it it takes time to build so me
being 38
I'm not dating anybody around my age at
all so I'm dating somebody right now
that's 15 years older than me and that
is
you know it's been going really well
um but they have I feel like they just
once they have it and they're older and
they're set obviously they're they're
going forward but with the women like
it's harder to what I'm trying to say
it's just harder it's easier for us to
come in and
be make life easy basically
but men they do have struggle they do
they can't just wake up one morning and
have it all together so
for me if I there was a 53 year old man
that you know
he's attractive but he's putting in a
little bit of work you know here and
there it just doesn't do it for me you
know
I think most of what I'm getting at is
you know we generally
tell when we talk about guys in their
Peak and guys that are really really
peaking in their early 40s or mid 40s or
whatever it is we generally tell guys
that they should really have their [__]
together by mid 30s early 40s at the
latest You Know Rich talks a lot about
you should be a millionaire buy 30 if
possible absolutely by 40.
they get so mad
so I'm buying everything you're selling
but I think what you're sort of saying
is even guys in your age range late 30s
early 40s are still from what you're
seeing
still have maybe 10 or 15 more years of
work to do before they are where they
should be to essentially be a prospect
for you is that what you're kind of
getting at 100 percent
Melanie what about you you've seen the
same things oh yeah
yeah that's right I wanted to ask you
the guy that you're seeing that's 15
years older who shifts together he's got
a good life he's uh he's a successful
man
yeah yeah and he actually watches your
content too and I didn't not know that
beforehand so that was like I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full-length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out